the country just invaded its neighbor
and it's leading and you know I know
that people are going to have opinions
on whether or not you know it was
justified or whatever but leading the
the U.N security Council
and they are a belligerent in a war
that could possibly lead to uh total
nuclear war Global nuclear war a
thermonuclear exchange between you know
and they're leading the uh the security
Council that's I feel secure I I decided
I feel secure that was the council's
purpose they did their job I how would
they vote him in it says here Ukraine
was uh urging members to block but I
mean honestly the council probably is
more secure with having at least United
States Russia or China at the head at
the moment
the council itself I don't know if the
world's more secure but the council the
U.N is more secure as an organization
with a Powerhouse at the head